[Music]
it's been a four year plan
and it's coming to a close
today
[Music]
my name's honor and you're gonna say i'm
the classic overachiever i started a
school karate club and the food bank for
the economically disadvantaged while
never letting my grades suffer for me
high school is about getting out of high
school
and i'm going to the number one college
in the world honor my best and brightest
i have a connection with the admissions
people i had no idea i knew this in
ninth grade you are in my top four
choices
i'm tuning the g string wait did you say
top four
in this school of underachieving losers
there's only three people it could be
but only one is an actual threat michael
dipnicky i've got to get him to tank his
midterms what's the plan
hey michael would you be willing to
study with me yeah sure
sure
easy
the first wave of my campaign
throw the nerd off what's the matter we
should probably get to work because i
need a scholarship yeah you might break
the tempo
they grow up so fast
you call him home not obsessed with him
or anything time for the evening concert
just trying to figure him out everybody
ignores me but you don't this must be so
lonely yeah you get it i do
i think
i like him
that's just another obstacle to overcome
i'll destroy anyone who gets in my way
coming to my next show i'm going to call
your mom tell you do drugs
i just feel like you're pretending
i don't want to hurt him but i've got to
play dirty
you remember i took karate right
something's wrong nothing's wrong it's
been a four-year plan and it's coming to
a close today
here is a flyer from michelle the
flyer's like a tweet that ruins the
environment i'm gonna tweak that
[Music]
bye